hey I was gonna press my name Hey oh
yeah this is what the kids like a lot of
hand movements a lot of hand gestures
how's it going bros look what I got I'm
not gonna lie this is the second one I
have we completely [ __ ] the other one
I don't know how let's just play
because now we're gonna play a way
cooler game oh it's it starts right away
egg gang Michael this is supposed to be
a really cool VR experience
I love cool VR experiences I'm very very
excited and here we go check your
surroundings are they clear all these
legal [ __ ] just take me in the game
found one found two or car no Batman be
our embryo Jesus that's close
hey you can see the boss I can see the
boss this is the red one this is the
pink one oh that's cool I've always
wanted to bolt can eyeball myself oh wow
to ensure the best bargain VR experience
yeah I get it
nobody said on the bat symbol press the
move button to continue
no man I can't want that far back like
[ __ ] kiss the dumb [ __ ]
warning please stand as close as
possible to the bat symbol listen you
[ __ ] [ __ ] I'm telling you you need
to back the [ __ ] up I'm right here sleep
is right there okay I don't want to kill
sleepy is that a problem with anyone
I don't want care my pet back position
your headset within the target area
you're asking for a lot of things Bruce
it's okay cars around the front come on
Brucie look at me oh my god that's way
nothing to be ashamed of
oh my god I'm tiny bruising you and me
damn I think your father was scared to
she thick though hey
why don't we stop for ice cream on the
way home listen you're really freaking
me out like you're way too [ __ ] big
hey no it's daddy please kiss jewelry
hand it over
stay behind me purrs damn she think it's
[ __ ] her deluzy friend he that's I just
realized I'm gonna press the stroke and
I didn't mean to do it
I'm sorry Tommy alright just faster
Thomas back off just give her the neck
to cooperate what were you guys doing in
this cow mommy yeah
don't shoot me I will you know what when
I grow up I'm gonna put on a cape and
I'm gonna kick you your ass you see that
kitten oh [ __ ] you're waiting what
happens when you try to be a hero
um [ __ ] crisis breath smelled like
ass
rough night sir oh when did you return
hey how are you we're nosov your
movements would be appreciated a grand
or otherwise Oh
ah ordinarily I would beg you to take a
night's rest but let me tell you have a
situation
ah I'll explain danced ah uh ah yeah you
were looking for this I imagine okay
very good
I'll see you downstairs
do I get to play the piano I wonder if
I'm good
[Music]
[Applause]
alright [ __ ] it
oh my god
Batman in bed King welcome see Jeff
sequence initiated
biometric signature required this is so
cool thank Lord for BR what is this I
put my hand there hey that's it version
7 long like I got my knuckle ready for
deployment
oh there's tedious I've always wanted to
do this don't look gross MA
alright what do I do with this all I'm
wearing the suit okay cool
this is this is incredible guys all
right give me the arms get [ __ ]
on Oh
initiate dad can't seem to reach over
there
I got my back laughs [ __ ] yeah I got my
back look I need my bad hell man that
ready for deployment oh oh this is all
gone I'm Batman
I'm [ __ ] Batman for careful combat
man I was [ __ ] nice man oh I love
fabulous
oh damn dog I look so cool oh come at me
can white is a better tan I am Batman
right now I am so Batman right
oh my god let me put they're ready for
deployment
hell yeah adrenaline high tensile wire
[ __ ] yes [ __ ] ready got my back balls
and everything but breathing targeting
Here I am I fell down at Target I will
[ __ ] oh yeah that's why you ninny
forensics get ready for deployment
software update hey [ __ ] you
oh wait I got to do the voice sorry I'm
getting a little too excited here on
that man [ __ ] you and Batman Batman
scanning that's right I lost it
calibrated and high in time calibrate
what's a better tank these used
we're stucked on something I have a go
[Music]
that was so [ __ ] good you say that's
like me hi I watch this got it ha ha ha
[ __ ] yeah I got it
yeah that's right oh [ __ ] man [ __ ] yeah
bad man now it's time to fight some
[ __ ] crab cuz I'm [ __ ] bad man
oh gotta watch my arms I said that's
[ __ ] it can't wait for bad porn man
that's gonna be the best got and watch
my I'm going down I'm going down folks
this is the coolest I'll say this this
is the coolest VR experience I've had
like I am sexually aroused right now I
think anymore my god yes I am in the big
ball
oh man I just I got fully bonus right
now this is just too cool guys I feel
emotional I'm rubbing my nipples but
it's not for me it's because I like it
just makes this situation better it's
the only thing holy [ __ ] alright so here
we are the joke that son of a [ __ ] oh
wait I know when I can brief you on the
situation shut up
yeah yeah I'm listening what is this
collecting blood sample Oh
well that's you wanna drink some I call
this one the bat ball Oh
oh [ __ ] yeah you look good
Oh guys I realize this is a little weird
but right now I could be making out with
Batman and I kind of want to try it out
marzia please it's nothing weird it's
just I wanna I want to make out with
that no don't turn your face around
paint
it's a weird that we're both have our
eyes open oh [ __ ] that's [ __ ] weird
man that is really [ __ ] weird Eric
monster Grayson's tracking [ __ ]
my now I'm Batman that's where I [ __ ]
am of course
yeah this that's a hat someone has a
hand in name that's an apple
I love a Apple let me grab that [ __ ]
app
all right we're down there yes
why wasn't I clear why didn't I stop it
no David recorder yeah I need to find
out who did this I was arguing with the
forensics scanner will help me identify
the killer who killed you buddy you have
such a tight ass multiple trauma caused
a death cervical fracture it broke your
neck who are the best fighter I ever
trained how did they beat you if I can
identify the precise moments when your
three main injuries occurred it might
help me establish your killer's identity
Oh got it
someone arrived talked to so I'm playing
it with my hand that's a four oh [ __ ]
that's cool
[Music]
I'm so turned on right now guys
that was that her killer was fast strong
but that wasn't why they beat you I knew
exactly how you fight
how are your other two injuries
sustained there must be a clue in the
reconstruction oh you left almost oh
[ __ ] nothing here I need to study the
points when you were injured
the killer anticipated your move and cut
off your escape I know you dick
you'd never back down from a fight oh my
god this is so crazy
no she's badly injured no longer oh my
god your killer showed no mercy why did
the killer flee the scene what did they
see there a full handprint the witness
was Jackie Flynn local criminal a known
associate of the penguin I need to pay
penguin a visit I'm Sonic
wow I should have been here helicopter
part had anything to do with your murder
mom make him regret it
make me that's not where I shot are you
alright
perhaps you should take a moment no time
I'll grieve when I know Robins safe
I'll go wanna help
robbing a muppet Archaea look of--my
boss please wait where are we run shanks
whoa I'm glad we had this chat but it's
not me I know you're scared
is that the witness we found the witness
at least you're not blown up
not like three of my best guys not like
my bloody cloud sorry at me
oh oh that's right I did that only
managed oh hey buddy buddy buddy buddy
buddy I'm just gonna talk to you little
Jesus I know why your ear your little
buddy shine kick the bucket today
well I bloody did that do it well then
who did I swear
last night one of my boys comes back to
the club bloody terrified is he says he
saw your boy done in said you be after
him last thing he says oh I can come see
Lucy ma'am
happy for I you want your witness what
you said to move some banner love you
oh no I give up hey right now move an
inch and you're dead the backswing is in
bounds well I [ __ ] died if I take out
a gadget that's been my fire
but - as he shares him over you alright
guys I give up you got me turn around
alright guys win turn around
Batman you got me - open it
and you're - Wayne is in bouncer please
identify the targets to be neutralized I
guess my friend converter is against
some doctor oh ha ha
that's what you got IRA laughing now
Schumer just wait okay it'll be over
soon
Batman [ __ ] you [ __ ] you I am it sing it
louder now I'm Batman
who's Batman UNIVAC Manta I'm Batman
sign your life shock kids Oh
if his disappearance is related to
Master Grayson's murder there must be a
clue in that morgue I am the baddest man
who are the baddest boot that is a dead
guy right Oh Dave set oh no the victims
of the iceberg lounge bombing oh look at
that
a piece of the detonator lodged in the
adductor muscle of the victims thigh
there could be shrapnel anywhere in the
bodies oh my god there's one in his head
a detonator fragment lodged in the
victims skull
we got something bit me four to five oh
my god I got it on my first try
there we go let's get the dead body out
of the bay clap it up everyone we got
clap it up everyone together dead body
hey how you doing buddy don't worry
buddy don't lock the occupied room don't
look it's getting water in the alignment
blood generating reconstruction I mean
it's a puzzle I like puzzles all right
so this one definitely when here this is
really cool a 3d puzzle and voila superb
yeah my meze oh that is it they're
demolishing an old train system beneath
founders on them hey super I'll be the
killers hideout if I target our sinners
on this area maybe I can pick up Robins
transmitter scanning this gamer thing
hey wait a minute guys in it I want some
girls all right
he's alive but in danger I'm come out no
anyone but Robin oh I was jaqen always
time to find Robin
what's your ceiling ah
oh [ __ ] yeah I'm in the sewers
I am back man hey that's a cool car I
wish I could have driven it but let's go
boom BAM well I found it hey go man man
got it Oh Oh your gift now I know I know
I've gone a little bit overboard with
that Trevin
rabbit oh it was a trap oh what a
thought yeah you're just in time for my
daring escape rabbin how you doing
Rambin I follow the trailer beside let
down here whoever it was I didn't see
them coming hey buddy would you mind
holding this it's graffiti some kind of
Joker copycat maybe a wrong and who are
you calling copycat robbed another three
let's get out of here
how did we're both track to clean this I
got to do man how they run orders are
writings written in here I did it I bet
I met it
[ __ ] yeah okay the panel's open it's
like some
my boyfriend now don't worry Robin a
shoe [ __ ] yeah that's a good-ass it's
not working anything else you could try
shut the [ __ ] up all right
oh there it is how about that here you
go buddy oh great hey I'm getting out of
here you're welcome you're welcome well
I'm out of ideas thing oh okay all right
uh hey won't you look at that rabbin
what about my girls likes Jim hang on no
do something Madden oh that's so [ __ ]
nice what does that mean I should do it
what does that do right Oh laughing
zapping oh no oh no no
that's too far man
I don't like it he ate ramen I'm [ __ ]
pissed
oh it's [ __ ] on I am so ready
I never bent this red in my whole life
I'm ready to March
Oh his fist
[Music]
it was all part of his plan how do I
keep falling in his trance sign it
what the [ __ ] is this place
anyone in there
a school Rindy Arkham Asylum that's cool
420 hilarious hey how you doing in there
buddy
hey I'm talking to you that's [ __ ]
creepy man okay what yeah
no you're creepy I don't like you that's
it okay fine what do you want kiss what
yeah kind of cozy in here innit
hey it's me Batman I am Batman
I am Batman Batman Batman Batman Batman
Batman Batman Batman Batman oh my bad
man I'm [ __ ] back man last night sir
I'll [ __ ] at you when did you return
ordinarily I would beg you to take a
night's rest but well we have a
situation
oh [ __ ] what's going on
focus we need to find out who did this
Oh dead there death are just in time for
my daring escape they follow the trail
like you said let down here oh I'm
Batman alright
enjoy the best fighter I ever trained
how did they beat you
[ __ ] yeah look at this bat muscles man
hell yeah
oh yeah [ __ ] yeah oh yeah look at it I
look good I am the Batman baddest of the
Batman I know this must be like a
serious moment what happened last night
one of my boys comes back to the club
bloody terrified is he says he saw your
boy done in said you be after him your
killer was fast strong but that wasn't
why they beat you they knew exactly how
you'd fight
[Music]
oh yeah together again
haven't you realized we're inseparable I
got the jump race in my head oh you what
oh my god oh [ __ ] that's why I didn't
see them kind with this graffiti some
come on Joker copycat maybe oh no I kill
you myself but sometimes you need a
little help from your friends
yeah yeah
[Music]
ah
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] man that was cool that was
real [ __ ] cool oh man hey work this
feels weird going out after a while I
never played with a beer for so long
Wow Alfie Rose enjoyed watching me play
it I was as fun as it is for actually
playing it because it's very cool it's
interesting like I've tested out a
little got [ __ ] sweaty I got I've
tested on all the beers now I think the
vibe is the best one I think the oculus
is alright but I but I think overall the
the PlayStation one wins because none of
them has a strong game like this that at
least last you an hour and it feels like
a full experience it's not as good as
vibe and it's not as good as oculus but
it's cheaper and it's easier accessible
for people so I think PlayStation is
they got it they got a tough advantage I
don't think it matters of what I say
about it but regardless I hope you boys
enjoyed leave a like if you did I had a
lot of fun and as always bet bro freest
[Music]